companies are struggling to find workers
labor shortages are acute it really is a
crisis you've probably heard a lot about
how the pandemic has various industries
dealing with the same problem filling
jobs and one occupation that's been hit
really hard
school bus drivers there's such a severe
shortage of them that in some places a
military escort of sorts for school
children heading home in massachusetts
members of the national guard are
driving kids to class so what's causing
the shortage and more importantly how
are families getting kids to school when
that yellow bus isn't showing up i made
calls to people across the country to
find answers to this important question
good morning
now bus driver shortages are nothing new
school officials i talked to say that
they've been an issue for years but they
say this is the worst they've seen it in
decades and it's primarily because of
the pandemic a recent nationwide survey
found that more than half of the roughly
1500 school transportation professionals
who responded describe their driver
shortage as severe or desperate
transportation officials tell me that
many drivers have quit because they're
worried about getting the virus while
others have left because they don't want
to comply with mask or vaccine mandates
and like many americans some have just
left for higher paying jobs and the
drivers that have stuck around they're
following the same rules that the rest
of us are they're calling out sick when
they have symptoms and they're
quarantining when they've been exposed
to the virus and all of these
pandemic-driven issues are forcing
last-minute cancellations that are
leaving parents scrambling portland
public schools is canceling about a
dozen bus routes fayette county schools
sent out an email announcing it would be
canceling four bus routes for thursday
morning so when the buses don't run how
are kids getting to class
because education is primarily a state
and local issue here in the u.s every
school school district and state is
dealing with the driver shortage in
different ways and some have had to get
creative
in massachusetts the governor has
enlisted the help of the national guard
yeah that national guard the military
force that's made up of citizen soldiers
who are usually called in for things
like emergencies and natural disasters
the national guard has been activated to
help address the pandemic over the past
year and a half and now its members are
taking kids to school
they're being trained to drive these
vans known as 7d vehicles while schools
iron out their driver issues governor
charlie baker's order makes up to 250
guard members available for the mission
i don't know what it cost at this point
but i can tell you that
like many other things associated with
covid
this back to school stuff will be
reimbursed by the feds the governor's
order has no specified end date and some
school officials in other states are
calling on their governors to enlist the
national guard as well
of course in many places parents are
taking time out of their work schedules
to help drive carpool and one band-aid
that's aimed at helping them stipends
where buses aren't running cps has
offered financial compensation to
parents to make sure
that they have an opportunity to pay for
transportation in chicago the public
school district is giving affected
families 500 a month to get their kids
to class
and some schools and districts across
the country are making similar efforts
at eastside charter school we are
offering every student 700
to get to and from school if we did not
have the stipend
i am certain we would not be able to
have children come to school and then
there are families taking matters into
their own hands turning to apps and
private services to drive their kids to
class the founder of ruby rides a
membership-based ride service for
families says demand for school trips
has risen about 60 percent and the
company has had to start a waitlist
the demand that we have is
surpassing the drivers that we have so
we are really working around the clock
to continuously onboard drivers so that
we can fulfill that large demand these
services can be a good alternative to
uber and lyft which have rules against
transporting miners but they're costing
parents a pretty penny the private
companies i talk to charge anywhere from
20 to 85 or more per round trip per day
so let's pick a number let's say a round
trip costs 60 bucks a day
times 5 days that's 300 a week times 35
weeks in a school year that's more than
10 000 a school year per kid as families
scramble to find rides right now
transportation officials remain focused
on getting more yellow buses back in
action some districts are boosting
hourly wages and dangling bonuses as
high as four thousand dollars
others are trying to recruit former
police officers firefighters and other
drivers who have the necessary
commercial driver's license to drive
buses and some are even encouraging
teachers to add driving as a side hustle
after all their schedules are a perfect
fit
but until they hire more drivers current
drivers are often running double routes
to pick up more students and that means
a lot of kids are spending more time at
school than usual
thankfully i live within walking
distance of my daughter's school but for
those who need rides these temporary
solutions may need to stay in place
until around thanksgiving since it can
take two months to get a new driver
licensed and behind the wheel
so have you or someone you know been
affected by the bus driver shortage drop
me a line in the comments and let me
know how you're dealing with it and if
you like this video please hit subscribe
so you can join me as i cover more news
that's having an impact on our lives